Sega.
This is a dark time in the history of Japan.
For over 200 years, the Ashikaga shogunate has ruled the country.
But when its power failed,...
...Japan's greatest and most ruthless warlords could no longer be contained.
In 1477, the Onin War led to the fall of the old shogun...
...as thousands of brave samurais spilled the blood of their brothers...
...on the once peaceful islands of Japan.
Giant vessels battle to control the raging seas.
The land is divided.
The people suffer.
The soul of a country begins to die.
Ten legendary leaders will strive for supremacy...
...but only one will rise above all to crush his foes...
...and govern the nation as the new shogun.
Japan can be ruled completely by only one man.
A great warrior, a great wisdom, a great leader.
Now is your time to master the techniques your forefathers have given you.
Now is your time to overcome all opposition...
...to become shogun.
Now is the time for total war.